era un país conocido por sus duras
sentencias contra los consumidores y
traficantes a veces condenados a muerte
pero desde junio al consumo y la venta
de cannabis son legales en toda
Tailandia objetivo oficial de la nueva
ley promover el uso médico del Cannabis
pero en realidad es el aspecto lúdico el
que
dominan primer día de vacaciones para
estos turistas de Grecia y Alemania
se está convirtiendo en la nueva
amsterdam de Asia salvo que aquí no hay
límite legal para la compra frente a los
5 gramos diarios por persona en Países
Bajos un giro de 180 grados iniciado por
los militares en el poder decididos a
reponer las arcas del estado y reactivar
el turismo
el consumo de marihuana en la calle
Sigue estando prohibido fumar en público
sigue siendo castigado con tres meses de
cárcel y 670 euros de multa las
infracciones son escasas y son cometidas
sobre todo por algunos turistas un gramo
cuesta ahora unos 15 euros más que antes
pero por una calidad mucho mejor explica
los minoristas que intentan educar a los
consumidores las flores de buena calidad
deben ser claras como esta Esto es lo
que he estado Esperando que ocurre en
Tailandia durante años para mí tiene
mucho sentido que por fin suceda y puede
abrir mi tienda de cannabis
Aunque la venta a menores de 20 años
está prohibida las tiendas no comprueban
los pasaportes de los consumidores Más
allá de esta industria recreativa
tolerada por las autoridades existe
también una industria del Cannabis
medicinal en Tailandia como esta granja
a 250 kilómetros de Bangkok todos los
días un Isa bien a inspeccionar a sus
bebés 4000 plantas de cannabis sembradas
en agosto de cultivo ecológico sus
flores se cosecharán en dos meses
he invertido tal vez dos o tres millones
de bats
el equivalente a 60.000 euros esta
antigua funcionaria de sanidad se ha
convertido en una empresaria experta en
thc la molécula activa del Cannabis que
desencadena sus principales efectos
Tailandia se convertirá en el país
experto en el uso del thc del Cannabis
superamos a otros países a Estados
Unidos O a Canadá el gobierno ha
prometido proporcionar un millón de
plántulas a los agricultores para
revivir un cultivo que existe desde hace
al menos 350 años
el rey rama quinto pensó que la
marihuana podía curar enfermedades
que la plantaran en los bosques
así como en las montañas de las
provincias occidentales de Tailandia
[Música]
o en el sur del país todas estas zonas
donde hay mucha malaria
desde que nací he visto plantas de
cannabis mis abuelos y mis padres las
usaron las probé y probé con ellos nos
trataron nos curaron
costumbres creencias no verificadas por
la ciencia pero muy extendidas en el
campo tailandés junto a la plantación
hay un hotel de lujo donde sumisa ha
abierto esta clínica Incluso el refresco
de cola aquí es a base de cannabis los
pacientes con enfermedades incurables o
benignas que van desde el cáncer
terminal hasta el simple insomnio cree
que el aceite de cannabis aliviará su
dolor en Tailandia la publicidad de los
supuestos beneficios del Cannabis no
está regulada tampoco existe la
obligación de informar a los clientes de
los riesgos asociados a su uso estos
tratamientos alternativos a base de
hojas y raíces es lo que buscaba esta
señora que tuvo covid durante la
pandemia no puede ir a ningún hospital
Así que lo que hice fue beber agua
hervida con hojas de cannabis durante
tres días sin tomar ningún medicamento
puede reanudar mi vida normal mientras
que mis amigos que tuvieron covid y No
tomaron Cannabis se sintieron débiles
durante mucho tiempo cansados
una opinión que no comparten la mayoría
de los médicos
es un regalo creado para la humanidad
hoy en día en Tailandia cualquiera puede
cultivar Cannabis como esta pequeña
granja en una casa de Bangkok estos
creadores Solo tuvieron que registrarse
en el portal del gobierno para obtener
una licencia como más de un millón de
personas desde junio
las semillas vienen de Países Bajos
huele bien parecen mangos tailandeses
estas granjas existían pero en secreto
operaban discretamente
pero ahora no tenemos que escondernos
podemos brillar Nuestro objetivo es
convertir a Tailandia en el país del
Cannabis en Asia
pero una parte del mundo médico está
preocupada por las consecuencias para la
salud pública 1800 galenos han firmado
una petición contra esta legalización
denuncian los riesgos de adicción y los
efectos nocivos demostrados en el
desarrollo de los adolescentes
si se compara con otros países que el
cannabis antes que Tailandia
como Canadá o algunos Estados Americanos
allí hay más regulaciones sobre el
cannabis si compras cigarrillos hay una
foto que explica lo peligroso que es
pero para el cannabis No hay ninguna
regulación simplemente destacan los
beneficios estoy muy preocupado
bajo presión el Gobierno ya ha anunciado
un marco legislativo más estricto
para muchos es demasiado tarde La Caja
de Pandora está abierta